hello and welcome to this video playing
vho probably so now what you try
something else do a simple setup here
against the Dutch and you know I intend
to play a foursome
g5 is usually played this is possible
but it's kind of a comfortable setup for
white it's nothing nothing special but
it's it's okay maybe I can cast along
here through 4-h form okay but do this
now that possible takes okay let's start
with h4
probably still not going to check meat
in there quickly maybe maybe you like
g64 Knight f4 c5 wow it's really working
or why why is that working as I take it
I've got a ton of threats here 96-97
for because of the discoveries
I mean ya understand the general idea
because it opens up everything in the
bishop and so on but I have threats in
particular night X is six okay this is
preventing preventing night X is six but
my god as you see for I want to play
Knight g5 is also possible let's do this
I wonder if he has screen a five at some
point I mean I expect age six and then
I'm not totally certain what I'm doing a
couple of interesting moves actually
unite age seven is probably possible
[Music]
mine are still Queen f5 wow she fibers
hanging with a check Bishop f5 Bishop
takes g5 I can take on age seven though
King takes Bishop f5 checkpoint a group
t5
okay is he finally going to play um
Queen a5 by now okay the alkene night is
six on it's that it's that killing it's
that bad for me no I I think it's
possible
winning the exchange
Queeny eight it's Ruby it's a check Wow
yeah I think it's a check on eBay -
thinking oh my god
who painted yourself in we are Queen to
b6 problem but it's no compensation the
TF agents that fell apart I think c5 is
probably not working this field so yeah
normal normal stuff each form prevents
the night prevents prepares the night
jumps and yeah 95 95 I'm a bit surprised
that the engine is so optimistic for me
I mean that white is a little bit better
I think it's easily imaginable but more
than one pawn sounds excessive okay I
see five I don't think works
I take Jake Knight g5 is even stronger
[Music]
yeah that's actually not very difficult
him now I have the same idea but
attacking age 7 yeah that is a disaster
okay I mean this is good but the other
move was even stronger now g5 and now
Knight f5 yeah I was expecting h6 and
there wasn't quite certain what I would
do
probably Knight to e4 Knight age 7 is
also interesting
you know I don't think he's got anything
serious you hear something like that
97 it's just taken here I guess and it's
little real danger here you're all
making a midnight f5 and this is some
probably just losing up night age
several dead for it falls apart
there's just nothing nothing to be done
Queen b6 is what I expected
it's interesting the engine doesn't even
want to take yeah as I said looks very
strong threatening mate so black has to
take and then the open a trial wins them
there's no counter play and yeah the H
valve whoo scary okay guys thanks for
watching